fragen wir Markus Kolb in Zürich ist das
jetzt der Beginn der großen ukrainischen
Gegenoffensive oder ist das eine Art
Vorgeplänkel
ich denke es sind verschiedene
Schauplätze die wir hier
auseinanderhalten müssen also ich habe
ja früher schon gesagt die ukrainische
Gegend Offensive hat wahrscheinlich
schon begonnen allerdings würde ich die
Kampfhandlungen hier in bachmut nicht
dazu zählen was die ukrainische gegen
Offensive sicherlich zurzeit macht ist
z.B mit den britischen stormtellung ist
das ähm die russische Logistik sowie
russische kommandozentren hinter der
Front herauszunehmen ähm also sprich
langfristig solche
Vorbereitungshandlungen erstmal
einzuführen bevor dann der mechanisierte
Durchstoß irgendwann erfolgen wird das
braucht allerdings Zeit und und gute
Vorbereitung ich denke in bachmatt sehen
wir etwas anderes da sehen wir eher das
Ausnutzen einer temporären russischen
Schwäche das Problem ist folgendes als
pregorien so langsam gemerkt hat dass
seine Wagner Kämpfer zunehmend
draufgehen und diese Leute die sind für
ihn ja kostbar nicht nur weil er ihnen
viel soll zahlt sondern weil er sie auch
teuer ausbilden muss sagte er auch
folgendes ab sofort werden die Flanken
jetzt von einer russischen Brigade
gehalten und ich spare mir meine Kämpfer
für meine eigenen Zwecke auf das führt
nun zu dem paradoxen Effekt dass die
Russen in der Stadt bachmut durchaus
Fortschritte machen also sie kommen so
langsam voran auch im westlichen
Stadtgebiet allerdings werden die
Flanken jetzt von schlecht ausgebildeten
mobix und einer ziemlich unprofessionell
geführten russischen Brigade gehalten
deren Kommandeure vorgestern übrigens
draufgegangen sind ja und jetzt werden
die Flanken von Norden und von Süden
ausgerollt das ist es ist eigentlich äh
paradox ja während während nach Westen
vorstoßen werden sie nördlich und
südlich von der Ukraine umfasst und wenn
sie nicht sehr aufpassen könnte es
tatsächlich sein das ist der Ukraine
gelingt sie zu umgehen ähm Nordlicht
südlich oder sogar in beiden Richtungen
und sie damit zu umfassen also das ist
ein interessantes Spektakel dass wir da
sehen aber das hat jetzt nicht zwingend
etwas zu tun mit der eigentlichen
Frühjahrsoffensive schauen wir
vielleicht gemeinsam um so ein bisschen
Orientierung zu bekommen einfach mal auf
eine Karte wir können hier sehen das
hier ist bachmut ich hoffe wir können
das einfach mal auch
auflegen wenn wir hier sehen das ist
nicht bachmut das sind bunte Streifen da
kann man nicht gerade viel erklären aber
einfach um auf die Frage jetzt immer
endlich die Karte also hier sehen wir
bachmut und was sie eben meinen ist das
brigotten hier Teile der Stadt hält oder
in die Stadt vordringt und sie eben
sagen die Flanken nördlich und südlich
dass das sozusagen das Ziel ist der
Ukrainer hier vielleicht die Armee
zurück zu
zurückzudrängen und eventuell sozusagen
einen Kreis einen Kessel zu schließen
aber die Frage an Sie ja Käufer ist man
sieht ja die diese Front ist ja
Kilometer lang und bachmut ist eben nur
ein Steinchen was man hier sieht wo eben
schwer gekämpft wird
hier unten haben wir sauber ist ja wir
haben Harke und viele viele andere
Städte gibt es denn Vermutung bei Ihnen
wo vielleicht ein Durchbruch dann
versucht wird es gibt auch viele andere
Analysten die eben sagen die Ukraine
versucht vielleicht in bachmut viele
russische Truppen zu binden um dann
einer ganz anderen Stelle wir haben es
gerade gesehen die der von Verlauf ist
kilometerlang hunderte Kilometer an
einer anderen Stelle dann am Ende den
Durchbruch zu schaffen wo die Russen
dann auf einmal nicht mehr so stark
aufgestellt sind
ja ich denke das auch also dieses Kalkül
russische Truppen zu binden das gilt ja
nach wie vor also nach wie vor ist der
Großteil der Kampfkraft von Wagner sowie
die Kampfkraft von zwei russischen
Brigaden in bachmut gebunden ich habe
schon häufiger darauf hingewiesen dass
das militärisch völliger Unsinn ist was
die Russen da machen also diese enormen
Kräfte nicht nur zu binden sondern auch
hin zu opfern für einen winzigen
Ausschnitt der Frauen wie Sie richtig
sagen also diese gesamte Frontlinie wenn
wir die Flanken mal abziehen in der
Stadt ist etwa 4 Kilometer Luftlinie
Nord Süd das ist also ein völliges
Missverhältnis von Ressourcen und das
führt man dazu dass die Front an anderen
Stellen einfach ausgedünn steht also
wenn wir uns mal die Strecke anschauen
zwischen saporicia und dann jetzt das
sind ungefähr 300 km und dort stehen die
Russen am dünnsten und ähm ich
persönlich denke dass wenn die Ukraine
einen mechanisierten Vorstoß Unternehmen
wird also nach Abschluss dieser ganzen
Vorbereitungshandlungen nachdem man die
Logistik herausgenommen hat die und so
weiter dass sie dann dort durchstoßen
wird um die Schwarzmeerküste zu
erreichen und von dort dann die Krim
bedrohen zu können wie wahrscheinlich
ist es denn jetzt erst einmal dass die
Ukraine F16 Kampfjets westliche
Kampfjets also bekommt und das
ukrainische Piloten eben mit westlichen
Maschinen ja russische Truppen angreifen
können
also ich denke man sollte da erstmal
ansetzen bei diesem sogenannten Begriff
der roten Linien mein Kopf wird immer so
ein bisschen rot wenn ich diesen Begriff
höre es gibt keine roten Linien es gibt
nur russische Täuschungsmanöver sage ich
immer ähm wir erinnern uns noch mal ne
die Diskussion die wir im Mai 22 also
etwa einem Jahr geführt haben wir
wirklich diese schrecklich aggressive
Artillerie an die Ukraine liefern das
sind ja dann keine Verteidigungswaffen
und überhaupt beginnt und so weiter und
so weiter was ist passiert genau sie
sehen also dass der Westen seine naja
sie können es jetzt Besonderheit oder
Feigheit auf jeden Fall sagen wir mal
seine Zurückhaltung so langsam auch gibt
und erkennt worum es sich bei diesem
Krieg wirklich handelt nämlich um einen
imperialen eroberungstrik Russlands und
das entsprechende Mittel eingesetzt
werden müssen um den rückgängig zu
machen das wird jetzt hoffentlich auch
noch den letzten besonnenen Menschen
klar nun ist es tatsächlich so dass
nicht alle Nationen die F16 haben aber
ja wie ich bin nicht ganz so glücklich
mit dem Beitrag weil die wichtigsten
Beitrag haben die USA bereits geleistet
nämlich dass sie dieser Koalition nicht
widersprechen das könnten sie nämlich
mit dem Argument das ist ein
amerikanisches Waffensystem und wir
genehmigen nicht dass das eingesetzt
wird
Großbritannien und insbesondere die
Niederlande haben schon vor längerem
also schon Ende März solche Bemerkungen
fallen lassen dass sie es sich
vorstellen könnten F16 zu liefern also
ich denke das kommt jetzt nicht von
heute auf morgen sondern das ist von
langer Hand vorbereitet auch Belgien hat
seit gestern schon angekündigt sie
Piloten daran ausbilden das hat
natürlich auch für andere Nationen den
wunderbaren gesichtswaren in Effekt dass
man jetzt sagen kann wunderbar wir
brauchen ja gar nicht liefern weil zum
Glück haben wir keine F16 also
vermutlich ist das in der Rammstein
Gruppe so ein bisschen abgesprochen
worden dass da jeder sein Gesicht waren
kann und dass man da eben eben trotzdem
militärisch das tut was notwendig ist
und die russische Aggression zu
neutralisieren also sprich die Frage ist
nicht mehr ob die Ukraine F16 bekommt
sondern wann und wie viele da passt die
Farbe wir haben viele Fragen jetzt
direkt an Sie Herr Kolb ähm ein User
schreibt sind die F16 denn sinnvoll
zurzeit einzusetzen da ist keine klare
Luft Überlegenheit gibt also was würden
jetzt F16 Kampfjets helfen was würden
Sie verändern wie würden sie das Blatt
irgendwie wenden
ja also es gibt im wesentlichen drei
Gründe für den F16 also das erste ist
was was der User zunächst mal selber
anspricht nämlich die Luft Überlegenheit
es ist nach wie vor so das russische
Kampfflugzeuge relativ ungestraft im
ukrainischen Luftraum operieren können
solange sie sich nicht allzu nahe der
ukrainischen Luftabwehr annähern das
heißt ein großes Problem für die Ukraine
ist immer noch das russische Kampfjet
überhaupt in ihrem Luftraum eindringen
und von dort aus marzflugkörper
abschießen können also das könnte man
zunächst mal wieder mit der F 16
deutlich reduzieren indem es einfach
wieder zu Lust kämpfen käme also indem
die Ukraine glaubwürdig auch ihre eigene
Lufthoheit durchsetzen könnte das zweite
was man auch sehen muss ist die Ukraine
kämpft im Moment mit Systemen deren
Lebensdauer und deren
Durchhaltefähigkeit zu neige geht
nämlich im Prinzip mit Ex sowjetischen
Systemen also der Micky Familie sowohl
mit ihren eigenen Flugzeugen die auch
mit Flugzeugen wie zum Beispiel Polen
geliefert hat aber man muss klar sagen
das ist die Technologie der ehemaligen
Sowjetunion die geht nicht nur aus aus
zeithistorischen Gründen zu Ende sondern
auch weil ein Kampfflugzeug einfach eine
begrenzte
Anzahl an Flugstunden hat die es
überhaupt als militärischer Effektor zu
gebrauchen ist das heißt wenn man jetzt
nichts machen würde dann würde sich
einfach die ukrainische Luftwaffe über
die Zeit abnutzen und irgendwann würde
die Ukraine ohne Luft dafür darstellen
also dann technologischer Ersatz ist auf
jeden Fall notwendig und da macht es
natürlich Sinn auch im Sinne der der
militärischen Zukunft der Ukraine und
der NATO Mitgliedschaft die sich auch
ankündigt dass man eben auf westliche
Systeme wechselt der dritte Punkt ist
dass die F16 eigentlich das beste
Abschluss System für die sogenannte jdms
Munition ist das ist also das was ich
früher mal als Ikea Bausatz bezeichnet
habe also man kann damit normale Bomben
umrüsten zu Präzisionswaffen das ist
also ein Heck dass man dran schraubt und
Kleid Flügel oben dran und diese jdms
das ist eben eine eine Waffe die von
Kampfflugzeugen aus eingesetzt wird
und es gibt eben den den sehr großen
Vorteil anders als zum Beispiel bei der
Artilleriemunition das ist derzeit eine
halbe Million von diesem Pilz weltweit
gibt also die werden schon seit bald 25
Jahren produziert das heißt hier haben
wir insbesondere das nicht was wir immer
bei der Artillerie thematisieren nämlich
Munitionsmangel wenn Sie das
zusammennehmen dann würde das die
Ukraine sicher auf einen neuen Level
militärische Fähigkeiten heben
also klare Argumente und Gründe warum
die F16 ein ja ein Blatt wenden kann
oder eine große Rolle spielen kann
weitere sehr interessante
strategisch-technische Frage Legolas
schreibt fragt warum hat die Ukraine die
krim-brücke mit Storm Shadow noch nicht
angegriffen und Carsten Conrads fragt
macht eine Gegenoffensive überhaupt Sinn
so lange über die Couch Brücke noch
Nachschub Rollen kann
ja zur kerzbrücke werde ich relativ
häufig gefragt also ich denke das kann
man mit zwei Argumenten umfassen ähm zum
einen denke ich dass wenn die herzbrücke
angegriffen wird dann wird das der
Schlusspunkt der gegen Offensive sein
weil ich denke die Ukraine wird Russland
bis zum Schluss eine exit Optionen offen
lassen weil wenn sie glaubwürdig drohen
kann die Südfront einzunehmen oder die
Frauen zu spalten dann denke ich ist es
sinnvoll den Russen eine Möglichkeit
offen zu lassen wie sie ihre Truppen ab
können und dafür brauchen sie die Brücke
von kerath denn das ist die einzige
Landverbindung nach Russland hinein wenn
man in dieser Option nicht geben würde
dann wären sämtliche Truppen auf der
Krim gefangen die Schwarzmeerflotte ist
logistisch nicht in der Lage die zu
evakuieren das heißt dann müsste man sie
zusammenschließen und es ist denke ich
für die Ukraine eleganter diese Option
bis zum Schluss offen zu lassen weil es
dann nämlich eine Entscheidung der
Russen ist ob sie ihre Reserven sinnlos
opfern oder ob sie sich freiwillig
zurückziehen das ist also durchaus eine
Möglichkeit den Krieg früher zu beenden
ist eigentlich paradox indem man die
Brücke nicht beschließt beendet man den
Krieg früher aber ich denke das ist
sicher ein Motiv dass da hinein spielt
wenn Sie die Logistik ansprechen für die
Logistik ist es vor allem entscheidend
dass sie nicht aus der Krim herauskommt
also sprich ähm es ist weniger schlimm
wenn in die Creme über die Brücke von
Lieferungen kommen aber sie zum Beispiel
das Eisen bei den Eisenbahnknoten bei
John Koi herausnehmen oder die sagen wir
die verschiedenen Luftblasen die es gibt
auf der Creme von der aus Angriffe
geflogen werden das wäre sehr viel
wirksamer weil dann würde die Südfront
und auch die Don was Front größtenteils
ohne Nachschub da stehen und relativ
schnell kollabieren
jetzt haben sie einen Punkt ja schon
angesprochen dass einerseits oder wir
haben es ja auch schon gehört dass
selensky wahrscheinlich versucht und
vielleicht auch mit einer Offensive noch
ein bisschen wartet bis mehr gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge da sind um eben vielleicht
auch eigene Verluste zu verhindern oder
damit sie nicht so groß werden Martin
Schmidt fragt jetzt hier zu den
Verlusten auf beiden Seiten weiß
eigentlich irgendjemand irgendwie genau
wie viele ukrainische Soldaten bisher
getötet wurden
also wenn wir zunächst noch auf den
vorigen Punkt eingehen man muss sich
immer eines klar machen dass die Ukraine
eine sehr erfolgreiche des
Informationsstrategie betreibt was ihre
Offensive angeht zu hören also äußerst
widersprüchliche Töne mal heißt es wir
haben schon begonnen mal heißt es nein
der Boden ist noch zu schlammig mal
heißt es ja erwartet bloß nicht zu viel
mal heißt es doch doch wir werden ganz
sicher demnächst durchbrechen ähm das
ist denke ich Teil einer bewussten
Verwirrung
die mindestens doppelt so hoch liegen
und dazu kommt es und das weil es
interessant wegen ihres Beitrags dazu
kommt eine deutlich schlechtere
sanitätsleistung der Russen das heißt
also wenn ein Russe auf dem Schlachtfeld
auch nur leicht verwundet wird dann ist
die Chance relativ hoch dass er trotzdem
stirbt einfach weil er nicht evakuiert
wird er wird einfach liegen gelassen
oder bei den Hinterland die die
Sanitätsversorgung einfach viel zu
schlecht ist und das führt dazu dass
Russland nicht nur an höheren Anteil
verwundete hat sondern auch dass viele
diese Verwundeten eben nicht wieder äh
für den Krieg zur Verfügung stehen
sondern sterben oder dauerhaft invalid
bleiben und wenn Sie das Zusammenrechnen
dann kann man mittlerweile davon
ausgehen dass die ursprüngliche
russische Invasionsarmee von etwa
170.000 Mann weitgehend außer Gefecht
gesetzt ist und jetzt zunehmend durchs
ersetzt worden ist also durch
mobilisierte die gar nicht oder nur
schlecht ausgebildet sind und das muss
man eben im Hinterkopf haben wenn man
sich diese diese Verlust raten anschaut
also nicht nur wie sind die jetzt weil
die spiegeln im Wesentlichen die
vergangenen 12 Monate der Kriegsführung
wieder sondern wie werden die sich in
Zukunft entwickeln und auch da neigt
sich die Waagschale deutlich auf Seite
der Ukraine und wenn ich das sage das
hat nichts mit Pro ukrainischer
Propaganda zu tun sondern das ist
einfach das nüchterne durchrechnen von
Fähigkeiten und Verlustraten und ich
sage das immer wieder immer wenn der
Krieg schlecht läuft dann dann kommt die
ganze Geisterbahn wieder hoch von von
den sogenannten Experten und den
sogenannten Verhandlungen die dann sagen
acht dieser schlimme Krieg sollen wir
jetzt nicht lieber aufhören und harte
Arme Putin er will doch nur Frieden ja
ja genau
ich sage immer wieder natürlich ist das
ist das nicht schön darüber zu sprechen
aber schauen sich hin auf die brutalen
Realitäten des Krieges und fragen sie
sich wäre das alles passiert wenn Putin
nicht angegriffen hätte und dann haben
Sie eigentlich schon die Antwort auf so
etwas ja also natürlich ja im Krieg
sterben Menschen das ist so aber das ist
kein Argument deswegen einem Aggressor
das Wort zu reden
jetzt haben sie gerade noch mal
gesprochen von den mobix sie haben ja
auch sozusagen im ersten Teil ganz am
Anfang haben wir ja über Bach Mut
gesprochen sie haben ja auch das gesagt
was ein Kommandeur eben Tim Kröger ja
auch gesagt hat dass es sehr
wahrscheinlich ist dass man eben von
ukrainischer Seite versucht bachmut über
die Flügel vorzustoßen weil doch die
weniger vielleicht hart kämpfenden
erfahrenen gut trainierten russischen
Einheiten der normalen regulären Armee
sind und die Wagner Truppen im Inneren
der Stadt vor stoßen jetzt fragt Jens
Erik kurz noch mal darauf bezogen
besteht in eine reale Chance der Ukraine
die russischen Truppen in bachmut
einzukesseln was würde denn dann
geschehen werden die russischen Truppen
sich ergeben oder weiter kämpfen jetzt
gerade erst mal auf was sie sagen man
muss ja unterscheiden das eine sind sage
ich mal die regulären Truppen nicht so
gut ausgebildet auf der anderen Seite im
Stadtzentrum wohl vorgestoßen die Wagner
Truppen wie schätzen Sie das ein was
sagen sie ihre kurz
also ich denke spätere Historiker wenn
Sie diesen be diesen diesen Krieg einmal
untersuchen werden wahrscheinlich so
etwas sagen wie Präzision schlägt Masse
Russland führt diesen Krieg eigentlich
immer noch wie es wie es im 19 und auch
um 20 Jahrhundert Krieg geführt hat
nämlich mit mit einer brutalen
Überlegenheit an relativ dummer und
unpräziger Masse das heißt also am
massierten Einsatz von von Artillerie
und ähm massierten Einsatz von schlecht
ausgebildeter in Vertrieb deren Leben
eigentlich gleichgültig ist das haben
sie in der russischen Krieg Führung
immer wieder gesehen und diese Art der
Krieg Führung die stößt nun eben
deutlich an ihre Grenzen weil sie zwei
Dinge nicht hat erstens Präzision und
zweitens Mobilität und beide Elemente
benutzt die Ukraine eigentlich recht
erfolgreich um eben auf eine andere Art
und Weise zu kämpfen und das frustriert
eben die Russen wenn Sie schauen die die
Wagner vorgegangen ist in der Stadt sie
schicken zunächst malen also vier bis
fünf Wellen von mobix vor wir werden
sämtlich
herausgenommen ja weil die haben keine
Überlebenschance und die sechste oder
siebte Welle der gelingt es dann
vielleicht irgendeinen Graben
einzunehmen und diese Position zu
sichern und erst dann rücken die
regulären Wagner Kämpfer nach dir für
Pregarten wirklich wertvolle Assets
darstellen und die opfert er nicht
einfach so hin das ist aber eine Art und
Weise zu kämpfen die nicht nur
verbrecherisch ist sondern militärisch
auch unsinnig die kann also nur
durchhalten solange ein unbegrenzten
Nachschub an diesen untrainierten mobics
erhält deswegen heißt das ganze auch so
schön Fleischwolf von bachmut es es
klingt ziemlich ja aber sie sie haben es
hier nun eben mit einem Berufsverbrecher
zu tun den solche Argumente völlig
gleichgültig sind und sie sehen das was
sie Ukraine auf keinen Fall tun darf ist
sich in diese Art der Kampfführung
hineinzwingen zu lassen also quasi das
gleiche zu tun und zu versuchen
fanatisch die Stadt zu halten es ist
mehr so dass die Ukraine die Energie des
Gegners nutzt und sie gegen ihn wendet
und deswegen sagt okay wir lassen uns
auf so einen symmetrischen
Abnutzungskampf gar nicht ein sondern
wir suchen die Schwachpunkte und die
liegen nun eben nicht in der Stadt
sondern an den Flanken und versuchen
dann dort unsererseits Gegenstöße
vorzunehmen ob es Ihnen jetzt gelingt
Wagner wirklich einzukesseln das ist vor
allem eine eine logistische Frage weil
dann müssten sie wirklich nachrücken mit
größeren Verbänden denn diese diese
Flanken die sind deutlich länger als das
eigentliche Kampfgebiet in der Stadt ich
denke kurzfristig geht's für die Ukraine
zunächst mal darum die
versorgungsstraßen zu sichern also die
t0506 und die ähm die südliche Straße
die von ihr nichts gehen hineinführt
weil wenn die beiden sicher sind dann
kann die Ukraine eigentlich beliebig
Logistik nachgeben und dann die Russen
weiter abnutzen in diesem Raum also ich
denke schnelle Erfolge kann man sich da
nicht versprechen aber wenn das stimmt
was ihr Korrespondent gesagt hat dann
hat die Ukraine eigentlich in wenigen
Tagen Gelände Gewinne
Geschichte gemacht für die Wagner Monate
gebraucht hat um sie einzunehmen also
auch daran sieht man eben den Wahnsinn
dieser Krieg Führung auf der russischen
Seite und das macht wie Tim Krüger
gesagt hat eben wahrscheinlich auch
etwas mit der Moral der russischen
Truppen kommen wir zu Präsident selenski
der war ja nun in den letzten Tagen auf
Europatour Italien Deutschland
Frankreich Großbritannien und am
Wochenende hat Deutschland eben nun ein
gigantisches Paket geschnürt ein
gigantisches Paket an Militärhilfe
zugesagt schauen wir uns das mal im
Detail kurz dieses neue waffenpaket
enthält 30 Leopard 1 Panzer 20 Marder 18
Rath Haubitzen vier Flugabwehrsysteme
200 aufklärungsdrohnen und weiteres
Gesamtwert 2,7 Milliarden Euro
ganz kurz erstmal die Frage 2,7
Milliarden hat es so ein großes Paket in
der Vergangenheit eigentlich schon mal
gegeben
wie sage ich dass diplomatisch also aus
Deutschland nicht aber das will nicht
viel heißen weil Deutschland ja relativ
spät und relativ zögerlich angefangen
hat überhaupt die Ukraine zu
unterstützen also es ist schon mal ein
großer Schritt voran von dem Level ach
wir könnten ja mal 5000 Helme und ein
Feldspital liefern was wir noch vor 13
Monaten diskutiert hatten es klingt
heute so beschämen dass wir uns alle da
sind wir uns alle einig ich verstehe wir
verstehen die Ironie dass die lassen Sie
mich mal dass das kurz in ins Verhältnis
setzen also sie sagen jetzt gigantisch
ich glaube nicht dass das korrekte
Adjektiv ist also Dänemark alleine
liefert 100 Lego A1 aus seinem Beständen
ich denke viel mehr es ist das Nachholen
das längst überfälligen man darf sich
auch von der Dimension nicht täuschen
lassen also 2,7 Milliarden das klingt
jetzt zunächst mal viel aber wenn Sie
schauen was in der Zeitenwende für
Hausnummern genannt wurden also 100
Milliarden für die wieder Aufrüstung der
Bundeswehr wenn Sie schauen was die
ganze Welt bisher an unterst
Dienstleistungen geliefert hat in die
Ukraine dann nimmt sich das dann schon
etwas bescheidener aus das soll das
ganze nicht abwerten aber man muss sich
auch klar machen dass man nicht einfach
mit mit solchen PR-Aktionen im Sinne von
wir haben gerade ein riesiges Paket
geschnürt weiter kommt man kommt nur
weiter mit einer kontinuierlichen
Unterstützung und die ist ja durchaus
eingeplant also vom Finanzministerium es
soll ja weitere weitere 8 Milliarden
dann noch kommen bis 2032 und ich denke
das ist der eigentliche Punkt dass man
sich klar sein muss dieser Krieg endet
nicht wenn die Kampfhandlungen enden
sondern wir werden nach wie vor ein
feindliches und ein revanistisches
Russland bekommen an der russischen
ukrainischen Grenze und das bedeutet
dass man die Ukraine natürlich auch
langfristig militärisch aufstellen muss
gegen künftige russische Aggression
ja und das führt direkt zu meiner ja
letzten Frage die wahrscheinlich
wirklich die schwierigste ist Ihre
persönliche Einschätzung ich habe sie
eben schon gesagt Sie haben es ja auch
mitbekommen in dem Beitrag von Tim
Kröger e-hor der Sanitäter hat gesagt er
Träume wie alle davon endlich nach Hause
zurückzukehren lebend und gesund was ist
ihre Einschätzung wie lange müssen denn
wohl die Ukrainer noch davon träumen
wenn und das haben wir ja jetzt aus der
Ukraine von Herrn Schlegel und von Tim
Krüger gehört ja wohl offensichtlich
doch die große große große große
Mehrheit sagt der Sieg das Ende kann
erst sein wenn wirklich der letzte
russische Soldat ukrainischen Boden
verlassen hat wenn das also der Ziel ist
einer gegen Offensive etc dann ist die
Frage
wie sieht es auf einem Zeitstrahl aus
wie lange müssen die Ukraine davon noch
träumen und darauf hoffen
ja sie sagen jetzt das sei die
schwierigste Frage ich sehe das anders
das ist die leichteste Frage stellen Sie
die Frage bitte Herrn Putin in dem
Moment in dem er seine Truppen abzieht
aus der Ukraine ist der Krieg vorbei
Punkt und dann kann Ibo nach Hause so
einfach ist das ähm es ist immer ich ich
frage mich immer warum dreht man immer
die kriegsschulfrage um nach dem Motto
wie lange muss die Ukraine noch kämpfen
bis endlich Frieden ist die Frage ist
viel mehr wie lange toleriert man die
russische Aggression noch und die
russische Aggression beginnt natürlich
schon im Prinzip 2014 aber das worüber
wir jetzt sprechen beginnt mit der
Invasion 20 22 das heißt das ist nicht
in der Hand des armen Igor zu
entscheiden sondern entweder sieht Putin
das ein und dann ist der Krieg morgen
vorbei oder er sieht es nicht ein und
dann geht der Krieg so lange weiter bis
er es einsehen muss oder sein Nachfolge
oder pregorien oder wer auch immer dann
in Russland die Macht übernimmt aber aus
diesen harten Realitäten des Krieges
kommt niemand heraus auch nicht die die
jetzt Behandlungen fordern und damit
Unterwerfung meinen ich denke da ist
doch bei manchen noch ein Update des
Weltbildes wie Nico lange das so schön
genannt hat erforderlich bis einfach
klar ist dass wir hier nicht mit mit
irgendwelchen Appellen Weiterkommen
sondern dass das eine welthistorische
Frage ist die hier entschieden wird und
die erfordert natürlich
einen gewissen durchhalte Willen ich
sage Ihnen aber auch ich kenne keinen
einzigen Ukrainer der nicht die
Wiederherstellung der Ukraine in den
Grenzen von 1991 fordert und es ist auch
völlig berechtigt es ist das
völkerrechtlich einzig legitime
Ergebnisse dieses